Larry do you remember the first time
that you pitched one of your screenplay
ideas to a producer and it worked yes I
do
and it was to produce her name very
cross and it was an original idea of
mine I've gotten to the point where
pitching comes pretty easily to me
because I've been on both sides of the
desk and I know the drill and I know how
to do it but at first I was incredibly
difficult and it was always like the
sweaty armpit that that you know I mean
like yo and and and as you may I always
worry about with these interviews that
that that what everyone hears is me
stammering yeah I mean but I I remember
I remember telling this story and and he
was engaged and he was listening and you
can just ii-i've had pitches that I've
known everyone has had these two minutes
in it's just a slow death march
basically and and and you just want to
get it over with and say goodbye and get
out of the room but he was actually
engaged in listening and I knew it was
working because then he started asking
me questions and they and and they
weren't they were they weren't they
weren't you know the polite here's a
couple of questions now go away he but
he actually was curious and was and it
was a great feeling and it allowed me to
overcome a kind of a I I used to say
that I I started teaching so I'd learned
to talk in front of people and now you
can't shut me up because I was I there
was a lot of shyness I had to overcome
and so so so sitting in front of someone
and talking at that point in my life
wasn't easy but I could feel the eye
contact and I can feel him engaged in
the story and again when he started
asking me questions that told me he had
really been listening that was a great
feeling
and that may and that made pitching
easier until the next time I went to
pitch and it all went horribly and I and
I've had I've had them go both ways but
I developed a very thick skin about it
now and I you know I years ago pitched
an idea to Russell Brand's development
company when he I think he's I don't
know if he has that company still but I
was told by his executive it's too far
out for a Russell Brand and I thought
it's too far out for Russell Brett I've
got a run I'm ruined and so that one I
went away going Wow acid flashback I
guess or something but but so they can
go but they can go both ways but I just
I you know I I what I've developed over
the years is a real sense of humor about
this stuff and I i-i-i there's a there's
a great philosopher whose then a
touchstone for me forever named alan
watts and he once said I don't think
it's a it's almost like a riff on Jimmy
Page's
don't be respectable be responsible but
he said don't be serious be sincere and
I think that's so true and I go into it
and I never go into these meetings
trying to con someone or not not or tell
them something I don't believe in and
and but and I treat them very sincerely
but I've learned not to take them
seriously because if you because I've
seen people and and I could actually
tell some very dark stories about people
who take have taken this stuff way too
seriously and it's literally destroyed
them and I you know
I refused to have a body count like that
anymore in my life and so you go in and
you do your best and you tell them a
story and you think you believe in it
and if it's too far out for Russell
Brand what can I say I'm sorry
you